you're welcome to this video this is the
only bullet arena here on my chest
leeches I don't know the real I cannot
really figure out the name of that side
how it is pronounced but okay it's
bullet action it's been it's late in the
day and I just wanted some simple fun so
I'm joining this this bullet event
okay that's some kind of Banco whatnot
let's see okay I don't want to blunder
stuff yeah that is good well this guy
has a really high rating I'm just I was
wondering I he's playing really really
good I'm 95 oops
Oh where's the resign button on that
side I really don't see the resign bond
where's the resign button are here okay
I never I didn't resign that much yet
that on that side okay so not sure if my
window is just it correctly you said
right yeah I think we can we can live
with that
so what I'd see I'm not really in
bullets and bullet more yet John because
wrong they only ate it what wants to be
on a fade so here we go F for taking us
really stupid nobody would take and he
didn't so okay let's get on with that we
can go here okay let's go right in 4h
for got that pawn and now f3 is a big
threat I
so that one job I won't end up in quick
I also was quick in the game before but
I really I just dashed our moves and
didn't pay much attention to the quality
of the moves and I really had a good
opponent who played well so that guy
just killed me I don't know who that was
I don't know the handles on that side
yet so let's get this g5 poll all that
one not so good let's see how do i
progress you probably push that ok it
didn't happen so ah might be mad I don't
know who that is
some kind of no singular readers so okay
I have to get this bullet mode going
okay I'm reasonably quick but I really
have to adjust a bit bullet is not my my
main main occupation let's say Oh c6 III
is a little annoying move that my twin
chunks of material and it does so let's
get this here okey-dokey yeah I don't
have many squares admittedly but okay I
have enough material on him still a
piece up
okay let's keep everything protected
preparing Knight c3 here Bishop III is
quite a good move I think I could have
done that before
yep yeah I won't do this berserk saying
I really want to berserk I really want
to get into into Gears first yeah I'm
really behind here you have to get this
is so serious and yeah couple of wins in
a row
yeah quick quick quick it's that much of
the day he went right back to be one
that's kind of a curious it's a plea he
wants to trade off everything yeah well
my opening play wasn't the most
ambitious ever I have to admit that but
I was also thinking about playing
quickly and I managed that I really was
I was playing quickly it's just it's
just very equal sceptic Caleb to ji-sun
he's playing really well for 1600 I mean
okay I didn't pose them any problems
certainly but it also didn't make any
any huge mistakes or any mistakes for
that matter
do I get a pawn doesn't seem like it
maybe e4 can you retain him a bit ok
that's now I'm getting upon in the
b-pawn run run run little black on all
our hope is on you yep the thing is
promoting it's got one check so I'm okay
basically but behind how that guy is
playing very quickly who is that
actually says some way to find that out
yo so ah London we should be three okay
okay maybe it wasn't that bad
g5 no not coming okay let's let's do
that it's probably not Oh interesting
very annoying very annoying this yeah
that's that's bad that I just went into
a dead-end game that's not good oops
oops oops oops blundering this okay so
let's see that wasn't good
do I need to berserk I don't know I'm
probably I'm not I lack experience in
that event I don't know if I'm so far
behind that I I'm actually don't have a
chance anyway chance that's nice
winning chunks of material
yep so let's get stuff traded
unfortunately this takes more time even
it's not resigning him come on where's
this okay
yeah well I'm kind of not far away but
not enough somehow should have gone on I
don't know I should have played the
other move e5 at least that I know a
little bit
let's have some fun he certainly wanted
to attack but that's not going to happen
now off to see for him now let's see if
I can get the Queen into all of that
it's a bit slow but ok
Queen to age seven Queens your force and
so on
- guy checking on d7 it's gotta check on
g7 but ok I cannot do much anyway
no that's made that's made buddy
I had a threat it was probably bonkers
but it wasn't totally without any idea
ok so back back back back back back back
yeah a lakhan's defend those kind of
openings that I don't know a bad idea
for this kind of format just it just
takes time you know to adjust to
something you don't know and it's better
to play for me at least play it better
to play stuff I really have an idea
about can play much quicker
f-for okay I didn't win a piece
unfortunately you have to try let's
block that that's nice King is a pretty
decent blockading piece a father for the
full block here okay okay that's nice if
he takes that c4 c5 it's a very nice
blockade
let's see here night here's here's a
bloody quick poor as well so let's let's
get to this pawn I have slept upon ya
know here and the G part is running okay
Wow hmm so this is Gaia number one is
winning like mad man winning all games
so it's probably not possible to catch
him he is again you really played well
really well yeah that's a correct
opening and I stumbled into this bad
opening him white is just substantially
better
not much I can do I think it can
actually take on v6 yep Queen d6 Queen
b6 it's just not on it's just not
working okay I said my bun no nothing
impossible I don't know what that is I
know that I'm really rusty in bullish
but um nobody I can at least play with
the big guys just a little bit right
okay
and I said I'm completely rusty it's not
a great setup to be honest that I have
you okay is allowing that that's quite
nice let me win some stuff
your pets just to cons for pretty much
nothing
yeah night no no I just take stuff let's
just stick it my cheek before right
and don't have Ruby aid okay he didn't
know I can do that I can't be sure here
was even better no keeping that pawn can
still win it now oops okay it's it's too
many points whoa
it's just like oops every move even if
it doesn't make any particular sense
okay
fifth place that's not great but it's
very close yeah kings crusher is also
winning most of his games and he's also
winning quicker
yeah it's nice it's a good position oops
it's a good position but don't wind i
really quickly here it's a piece and
upon okay how is it in terms of Matt
game car it's okay the number of games
is okay but I keep getting losses so I
don't get this kind of this kind of
series in maybe I should bezerk once in
a while I set the right opening for
winning in 30 seconds I don't know
probably not probably not but okay let's
get going
probably is not the best idea I can i
define better it's not blunder blunder
h6 it was not protected I'm not playing
that terribly and just somehow not not
enough the other guys are just scoring
quicker and better and whatever units
I can take you three huh okay but I have
this all my time my time it was close
don't know if it helped that much but at
least I'm in third place have to be have
to be realistic the first place guy I
mean if he wins all his game games
nothing to be done yeah the Kings Indian
attack is a good bullet opening you can
put out number of moves quite quickly
it looks like a French defense low not
bad
we should talk you fry that's my idea
what is the night on b5 doing let's have
a look at it maybe he blunders it you
never know
okay let's send it back okay not a big
deal
one idea form is still not still not a
problem but also not helping very much
too slow here
no blundering g-form didn't didn't do it
do anything about it
man I'd you for not playing badly this
game playing badly he as well though you
want hangs okay let's see I can't read
my G form for a pin it might be that
might be okay
seems I'm winning f6 yep I'm we have six
maybe there was a checkmate somewhere
I don't know but I won't on time so
unfair I'm in third maybe I can still
catch Kings crush'
that would be something at least my
start was just to if yeah I always had
those losses you need you need to keep
the the series alive let's get stuff
closed here before it's not really a
good move but at least I played it
quickly okay Dennis help whoops Wow
mouse slip you just landed the proof is
there a full piece and that's the moment
where a mouse lab unbelievable stuff
full bloody piece okay get in Bishop
before here no maybe now you should be
funny that doesn't help
oops
I'm taking that
okay so let's wind endgame it's a
surprisingly tricky CJ group c3 yeah
still just just about okay no what am i
doing
ah stupid I'm giving him this bloody H
no I gave him the H power that wasn't a
good idea
no don't believe any of that
I won't on time I want a time okay
bullet is not for the high for the faint
of heart
you came let's see okay why be mad at
least we lost again
don't know - I have him again talk about
can you what is he doing here okay let's
at least a better position for me let's
see what happens it's not easy to get
anywhere serious that is a move without
a particular plan do I have any
particular plan here okay I can take now
shake him and look at the pond down you
got three and a four maybe you will
still go there let's push put pressure
here let's do that
okay I didn't and that's not good it's
not a correct sacrifice yes Queen to d8
unfortunately bad bad bad
never it was just kind of a too quick
move when I had him in this game I
really had a good position there a very
good one okay wastes planet button I
don't know it seems to be very strong
even never had a great position he was
defending very nicely their luster
luster lost patience there with this
sacrifice come on the least I would like
to get a winning against this guy I have
it okay I'm probably just too rusty and
it looks nice get in
very nice position now oops check okay
it's not a problem really
oops I'm taking that taking everything
here greedy greedy greedy but you don't
see any problem and that you should be
greedy anxious it pays off yep let's
meet them or you can trade Queens and
prolong the whole business Jam will be
difficult even to get second place who
is that guy is there some kind of
information there no following one
member since no idea I got him again
yeah Wow so can I get some kind of play
here night c4 or something if five is
good
f5 coming okay
let's take that I don't see it at the
moment why I cannot take it okay Navin I
look okay I know I have no I cannot do
something against him this is this is
all those losses here I mean not not all
of them but most of the losses I against
him this stops oh my oh my oh my
serious him okay Casey let's see what we
can do here I'm taking all your stuff
baby
it's a bishop I'm trippin my own bishop
he is is that really necessary
oh my god
completely idiotic it's not taking it
immediately for some reason maybe I can
get something here even gets in repeat
one I don't believe it in those key
games I'm playing real nonsense real
nonsense from this area completely
winning position yeah it would be one
hanging everything was hanging it was
just completely over
and believe come on no I am in this
nonsense iam oh yeah see 700k sees that
one joke for the joke just be one was
hanging Bravo and I'm trapping my own
Bishop there totally silly come on
yeah I lost against him before and it's
not nice it's a student of mine actually
so not a good idea big your own teacher
okay it was a stupid yeah okay let's
check him time and speed wise I'm okay
I'm really not too super snow or
anything no I wanted to go age six not
King age six Wow King age six that what
a brilliant move King age six cool okay
it's trying for some kind of attack here
with it's nothing it's not that
dangerous really I think six yeah can I
take one that I should have taken T
forever actually would have been much
easier
don't give me that crap
no you don't actually that's good stop
this stuff no I'm losing on time don't
tell me that no we was quick I at the
end no ha ha ha what a joke ok so what
am i playing for in this event yeah
number three Oh what I can try to defend
third place yeah it doesn't help yeah
ever lose against Casey winning and so
on okay the only thing that kind of
would help a little bit if I win de
against the number one guy but it looks
a bit looks a bit far off he just seems
to be too good at least today I'm not
that terrible in this time control it's
just that I never practice and it shows
okay so it's okay this passion just very
slow ish
so I just got a pawn there for basically
nothing put that here and off to the H
file and you can almost pre-move that
let's clean up to Jafar off we go to the
H file
what a funny piece configuration is Wow
difficult to move actually okay I can't
just take the Queen that one winning
some material him and the F pawn okay so
mr. Flannery
he actually overtook me because I cannot
get a single series and I can against
and I have fair play the wrong openings
here I really play the room openings and
have to play my usual stuff and now see
now I'm already already in trouble
oops forgot to take the rook okay I can
take the knight as well put a bit of
funny sequence of moves okay let's grab
this it's two pieces yeah I'm two pieces
of
okay let's it's let's run yeah yeah I'd
have six Queenie seven don't tell me
that some kind of how can I just move
the bishop no I'm not moving the bishop
just okay let's let's not let's not be
okay I can t and cut check and do this
so I won't actually at least win against
him that's good I got 20 seconds I
really managed that
okay so soup something why don't I go in
five and kind of I don't know why I'm
really every I'm just so much quicker
than my usual openings then I'm this
stuff it's a bad fringe so ever been a
good fresh air maybe but not for me
maybe it takes I okay that's actually
good news okay I'm getting some stuff
here oh that's nice bringing a pawn
there for nothing okay so let's see how
happy I can win this okay
active Kingdom it's really an advantage
the King position in the middle of the
board with my pawns running running fast
this night is especially a bit I know is
getting it back but okay not a big issue
I hope okay drama gives it takes quite
some time to win okay do I manage third
place it's close yeah that that first
guy scores insane just 92 it's
impossible okay it's not a great opening
in bullet White has all those tricks up
his sleeve yeah okay
that's I'm glad about this endgame
that's good oh my f seven i blundered f7
and he blundered everything and I didn't
take it and so on haha let's bullet for
you
rook d1 coming yeah should have kept
that five would have been a bit easier
okay let's run the April it's so good in
a pawn okay so I won on time just spend
something come on maybe that's time make
it five oh wow that's the most boring
opening ever
okay let's spice it up come on just oops
this is why you spies it up okay so
maybe I get to get third place in how
much time is left actually not that much
not that much time Knight to c7
No oh great
just so great king b1 they're the
ultimate pre-move eyes that's great okay
okay amazing
yeah okay yeah okay single areas single
reaches okay yeah good Stone reversed
it's quite nice because you can play so
quickly so pretty much refine what you
do so let's let's get it going twin h5
was already good this queen h5
threatening double check
Queen f7 is made here so quick one here
broke kukri oops come on I don't know
that it's not a good nah he's six okay
no Bishop d3 I thought what is this
really shouldn't speculate too much on
the pre moves they player play them less
often than you think even though you
might believe it is kind of the only
move and it is clear that it is coming
it is not they sometimes really play
different stuff okay
it has between two rows here for me
definitely come on I can trade some
stuff what can you do - 6 b2 hangs so
maybe I get that okay first of all let's
see if I can get rid of the Queen h5 mmm
he's really on one for that night each
form made each form
now a c7 xe7 is hanging what a shame
what a bloody shame but I have got a
pawn down I've got the b-pawn and I've
got 92 and here's 92 Wow it wasn't the
greatest game ever some way one that
sorry I got so I got third third place I
had just had one bezerk yeah so that was
really strong yeah that guy what what
did he do there he just lost one game
yeah so what is what is the moral of
story third place I'm a bit rusty I lost
all games against why be mad and I also
lost against his Casey the one game that
I had we only had one game when I
spelled this winner out of the opening
pretty badly I'd really like to know who
that is
I don't hey someone offers me 40 bucks
to buy my youtube channel no actually
you can offer me like 4000 and I don't
sell for 40,000 maybe okay guys I hope
you enjoyed that that was a little bit
of silly fun at least I had fun okay
yeah
till then till next video thanks bye